welcome back everybody I'll say it every
chance I get there is nothing more than
the Christmas spirit and the holiday
season I love it so much and Christmas
in New York is there anything better
it's magical walking around all the
lights it's it's chilly it's so
beautiful I love it all the lights the
music the time with family and friends
and then then there are the presents
which we love to get but we also love
giving that makes me feel even better so
here to kick off our weekl long holiday
gift guide Extravaganza let's welcome
back my friend podcast host and shopping
expert extraordinaire Lawrence
San everybody ready three two one
yeah we have we actually have our Kelly
CL and show OA to help us out as well
come on
o well we are celebrating Christmas in
the Big Apple and each taxi here is
holding the perfect gift so let's reveal
the first one shall we now Kelly this is
season 5 with us together yes and we're
learning about each other more and more
baby step dating so I have a question
are you a cafe latte or a double
espresso Girl cafe latte oh me too I
love that yeah it's a little I don't
need the extra no no I give I I give
that to you so no matter what your
coffee preference is you can have it at
the touch of a fingertip with this are
you
ready how good is
this oh know all
right I think they're happy I it's cofy
I think they've got the it is the MAA CM
5300 whole bean countertop coffee
machine with just the touch of a button
make custom Barista quality beverages in
the comfort of your own
home this ger engineered system really
does it all single or double servings of
coffee espresso cappuccino lattes creamy
milk froth and so much more so all you
have to do to decide for Christmas is
Kelly do you want your coffee with uh
Kalua or do you want it with
amoretto actually
Amarula it's really good all right it's
South African and it's I'm going to let
you do it now this is a serious piece of
Machinery right here and it is worth
$1,400 all right
okay so
do you think anyone anyone in our
audience would want one do you think
anybody all right well get your kitchen
counters ready because you are all
getting
Thea all right
let's now KY it's true this time of year
the shopping the baking the decorating
the finding Lawrence the perfect gift
it can be stressful I know so you know
what you give people that you love give
them a little bit of relaxation with
this I don't know what's
happening
this is the farun sense a massage device
that can help you improve everyday
Wellness that's right Mondays Tuesdays
Wednesdays you get my point right all
right
this device will make your loved ones
feel better all year long plus the best
part it's lightweight it's quiet and has
a patented triangle design that helps
you treat more than 80% of your
body I know I have one it's such a I
love them really I have yeah I have the
big one and the small one yeah have you
been stressed no I just I just like to
feel good I don't say now trust me
whoever gets this gift will smile and
and then say ah come here mama turn
around do it do it do it do it okay
ready okay three two ready
ah I'm so we're still children it feel
good right it's good easy I'll massage
you any time someone else does it yeah
all right who wants to melt their stress
away with
a well perfect you're all going home
every
I like this
one all right what's next final taxi so
here's the thing now Kelly we all have
those days where we want to work out
right but it's just too cold we do no no
we do right we have those days where we
want to work out but you and I together
we're like it's just too cold outside
yeah or we're feeling lazy or this is
something that you and I do oh we sit
there and we Daydream a vacationing of
all the places we'd rather be than where
we are right yeah kind of unless unless
you want to come to Montana then I just
dream of being there I was officially
invited to Montana
yes
so we got to get you guys to get up and
move and you get to get up and move with
[Music]
this oh no I owe this this is the
best this is the
best it's the hydro rower this brings
the on-water experience of rowing right
in into your home and you can still
travel the world from home with athlete
Le classes filmed around the world and
this is all the while getting a full
body workout that's high energy and low
impact seriously you can build are you
ready strength and cardio in less than
20 minutes good I want do it again I do
it again ready I love
it love I I actually have this rower in
my house I use this is my house I love
this rower anybody want one
anybody everyone of you is getting the
hydro rower close to 6 month
membership thank you
again be sure to down and share you are
beautiful with Laing available on all
podcast streaming platforms up next I am
singing with Teddy swim so don't go away
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home